excuse me Mr Reyes
he finished scraping the gum off that
lounger or what all right
everything right now feels so Out Of
Reach you always land on your feet bro
you're hymen
Jenny
God that makes me alive but do not open
it you went in to get us jobs and all
you brought back was a hamburger
okay I don't think it's a burger you
haven't looked what the hell is that
oh
how did you get it to do that I think he
likes me
[Applause]
almost acquired who said that
okay it's gonna be okay foreign
I I think I cut a bus in half
scared chose you but it belongs to me
hello you feel for your family
makes you weak
[Music]
the universe has sent you a gift and you
have to figure out what you're going to
do with it
whatever you can imagine
I can create
choice
oh it's like Batman stuff Batman's a
fascist